the day of the March election I get a
call from this reporter from The
Huffington Post and she wanted she
wanted to know about in particular memo
that had gone out from esns back in
August it's election day for me and
whatever possessed me to call her back
without knowing what she wanted to talk
about I'll never know and that's one of
one of the lessons that I learned never
take the call direct make sure you know
why the reporter is calling you because
I didn't have time to really prepare I
had to react to what she had to say and
she asked me about this memo she said
you remember I said vaguely so then she
proceeds to to put her own slant on it
and all of a sudden esns and ice in
sarasota had ignored problems that we
were sorry I got excited there though
that we ignored problems about the
pressure and the amount of pressure that
it took to actually register a logo on
the touchscreen which is one of the
things that that ended up being one of
the complaints and I guess it's
interesting that when everybody went to
bed that night and on Election Day I
didn't have any phone calls about all of
these issues it was only after the
results were in and the 18,000 under
beds were revealed that all of a sudden
all these folks that started saying well
they couldn't touch the machines i mean
in their vote wasn't registering and I
mean there were hundreds of them that
signed out
David's that are in the lawsuits today
but is they were all after the fact and
there were no phone calls coming in to
my office so it's a little bit of an
indication than today have been some
politics and fathers